we are sitting with you let's see what
happens game on the line Forest cash
right through the heart three-point game
Kansas State now needs a three to tie it
clock ticks Noel dribbles he's looking
for someone massoud got to put it up
Florida Atlantic
they are headed to the Final Four
oh
upset after upset after upset
Florida Atlantic at a Conference USA
takes out Kansas State
and they are flying high in South
Florida
the team from Boca
is going to Houston
their first final four in program
history
you wanted to get a three the defense
has extended doing a really good job of
swarming and let's keep in mind Brian
14 offensive rebounds 15 second chance
points the difference in the game for
Florida Atlantic